-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show"!
You're here! You made it.
Thank you for watching.
♪♪
Well, guys,
I want to say congrats
to the Cincinnati Bengals
and Los Angeles Rams
on advancing to Super Bowl LVI.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-Before the season,
the Bengals' odds of winning
the Super Bowl were 150-1.
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
To give you an idea,
there are better odds
of finding a rapid test at CVS.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
Than going to the Super Bowl.
-Wow!
[ Applause ]
-That's true.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I'm sorry."
-"Nope."
And this is crazy.
The Super Bowl is being played
in Los Angeles
at the Rams' home stadium.
[ Cheers ]
That's right.
Even NFL players
are working from home.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
We're two weeks away
from the game,
and experts are wondering,
if a Super Bowl doesn't have
Tom Brady,
can it still be called
the Super Bowl?
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
But this is the Bengals'
first Super Bowl appearance
since the '80s.
-Ooh.
-A lot has changed since then.
Back then, inflation was high,
there was tension with Russia,
and our president
was in his late 70s.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, and I saw that during
the Bengals/Chiefs games --
This just made me laugh.
Did you see the announcements
over at CBS?
-Oh, yeah.
-They have a great crew.
They're awesome over there.
But at CBS, they're doing
the halftime, talking about
the stats and all that stuff.
But they were just
in the worst spot
you could possibly be
on the field to talk.
But take a look
at the halftime report.
Look at this.
-...as we welcome
Grammy-nominated
singer-songwriter Walker Hayes!
-...this game...
[ Country music plays loudly ]
They score, they go down...
[ Music drowning out dialogue ]
-At what point do you consider
blitzing Patrick Mahomes?!
-I have no idea
what you just said!
I can't hear a thing
anybody is saying!
-[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
The speakers
are right behind them!
-Yeah.
It's the first football game
where the announcers
got concussions.
Unbelievable.
Meanwhile, the big football
story from this weekend
wasn't the games.
On Saturday, ESPN reported
that Tom Brady is retiring.
But then --
[ Cheers ]
But then,
conflicting reports came out
that said
Brady hasn't decided yet.
[ Laughter ]
This is what happens
when you let the CDC
announce your retirement.
[ Laughter ]
You just don't know --
[ Cheers and applause ]
6 feet, 3 feet, 5 days...
[ Applause ]
Brady was like, "I just
wanted to see who was happy
so I can destroy them."
[ Laughter ]
Let's switch gears.
Over the weekend,
former president Trump
held a rally in Texas
where he talked about
running for President
and said that if he won,
he might pardon
the January 6th rioters.
[ Audience groans ]
Even the rioters were like,
"Oh, no,
I don't think he can say that."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, there's no way --
no better way to announce
a presidential run than saying,
"I'll empty the jails."
[ Laughter ]
Well, the East Coast
is recovering
from a massive blizzard
that hit this weekend.
Boston actually got one of its
biggest snowstorms ever,
but that didn't stop people
from going out.
Watch this.
-Have you heard the news
about Tom Brady?
-Yes.
-What do you make of all that?
-I don't know. I don't know.
Is Gronk next then, I guess?
-I thought he had
a couple more years, maybe.
-Where are you guys
trying to go right now?
-We're trying to find
an open Dunkin' Donuts.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
-Can't find them.
-Come on!
-No, dude --
-That's real.
-Oh, my God.
-We did not do anything
to that tape.
That is real.
[ Laughter ]
Tom Brady, Dunkin' Donuts.
If they snuck in David Ortiz,
they would have summoned
the ghost of Sam Adams.
[ Laughter and applause ]
How Boston is that?
Fantastic.
[ Applause ]
You might have a problem
when you're willing to put on
ski goggles just to get
a pineapple Coolatta.
[ Laughter ]
But they weren't the only ones
who braved
the weekend's blizzard.
I saw that a couple
in Rhode Island
actually got married outside
during the storm.
Here's the happy couple there
right there.
Yeah.
And this is real.
Here's everyone
who showed up to the wedding.
[ Laughter ]
You know it's cold when your
"something blue"
are your guests.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a man who lives
on a lake in Canada
snapped a photo of a figure
that formed when waves
splashed onto the shore
and froze around a lamp post.
People are saying it looks like
the Grim Reaper.
Take a look at this.
-Ooh.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Everyone thought it was
the Grim Reaper
until they heard Grandpa
whisper, "Help. Help me."
[ Laughter and applause ]
After days of speculation,
today NFL superstar Tom Brady
officially retired.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Yeah. Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Yeah, when they said
everyone is quitting their jobs
during the pandemic,
they meant everybody.
-Wow.
-Yeah. To celebrate retirement,
Brady ate one carb
and instantly gained 40 pounds.
Unbelievable. I've never seen
anything like it.
But this is amazing.
Brady is walking away with
the most Super Bowl appearances,
wins, and MVPs.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's strange to say,
but he's basically
the NFL's Meryl Streep.
-Oh.
-I think it was time to go,
though, seriously.
You know you've been around
a long time
when you debuted the same year
as "The Thong Song."
That's true.
That's right -- right now,
Brady's backup in Tampa
is Googling where to buy
a football helmet.
Let's switch gears.
Apparently, former president
Trump's advisers
have convinced him to
stop promoting vaccines
because they're worried it could
alienate his supporters.
[ Laughter ]
Don't worry.
To win back his
non-science supporters,
Trump is going to stare
into an eclipse again.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right --
Trump is desperate.
Right now, he's like,
"I'll do anything
in this whole flat world
to win you guys back."
Hey, guys, listen to this.
Yesterday,
officials caught a chicken
trying to sneak
into the Pentagon.
No one really knows
what happened.
The story is so bizarre,
it actually inspired me
to write a tiny song.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ There's a chicken at the
Pentagon, and no one knows why ♪
♪ Are you a normal clucker
or an undercover spy? ♪
♪ A chicken at the Pentagon,
and we're at a loss ♪
♪ Should we throw you in a
prison or some barbecue sauce? ♪
♪ A chicken at the Pentagon,
oh, what a crisis ♪
♪ You get 25 to life
or 11 herbs and spices ♪
♪ Pentagon chicken,
you have our attention ♪
♪ You're raisin' our suspicion ♪
♪ 'Cause you do not have
permission ♪
♪ Our government's
panic-stricken ♪
♪ Their heart rates
have quickened ♪
♪ Were you on a mission or are
you just finger-licking good? ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Back to the monologue.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news.
Tesla just released and sold out
of a new product
called the TeslaMic,
which is a set of karaoke
microphones for their cars.
It's gonna be weird
when drivers get pulled over
and they're like...
[ Auto-tuned ]
♪ What's the problem, Officer? ♪
♪ I thought
the speed limit was 55 ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, this is cool, too.
I saw that Jason Momoa
is joining
the "Fast & Furious" franchise.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's amazing.
And Vin Diesel
is so excited about it,
he actually made his own teaser
trailer for the next movie.
Vin made this. Check this out.
♪♪
-There's nothing
more important than family.
And families get stronger
when you add a new person
to the family.
Jason Momoa is leaving
his fish family behind
to join us, his land family.
But the fish
are still his family.
The sharks are family.
The dolphins are family.
Anything in the ocean is family,
even the boats.
"Fast & Furious 10:
Norwegian Cruise Line."
-Oh, interesting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow! That's what it's about?
That's what it's -- Amazing.
-Wow!
-Some TV news.
Paramount+
just started production on
a "Grease" prequel series called
"Grease:
Rise of the Pink Ladies."
Yeah. It takes place before
the movie "Grease,"
so in this one,
the actors are only 45.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-[As Travolta] Geez, Sandy,
I can't believe
I'm in high school.
It's, like, crazy.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-"My hip."
-Yeah, I know. Yeah.
My hip broke.
Yo, I can't believe I gotta
get hip surgery, right.
[Normal voice] Guys,
there was a new episode of
"The Bachelor" last night.
You know we love
"The Bachelor" here.
And it was a pretty
intense showdown between
Elizabeth and Shenae.
Now, the show
can get pretty emotional,
so I thought we could help.
So here's that moment revoiced
with the least-emotional person
we know, Siri.
This is "Let's Get Siri-ous."
-[Whispering]
Let's get Siri-ous.
-I was upset. I'm mad.
I'm angry.
In the house,
you make me uncomfortable.
You're toxic.
-Can you define a circumstance
of bullying?
-Sounds silly, but you made
shrimp the other day, right?
You asked if I wanted some.
I was like, "Wow.
She is being really nice.
I'm going to take some shrimp.
Me and Eliza made some shrimp,
and I'm like, "Hey,
let me exchange the offer.
Let me see if these girls in
the hot tub want some shrimp."
-Does this sound like
bullying to you?
-Please, Elizabeth.
No one turns
back to even say just,
"Shenae, no, thank you."
-I wasn't outside when
you offered people shrimp.
-You were in the hot tub.
-I have been nothing but kind
and respectful to you
in the house, and as soon as
Clayton comes around,
all of a sudden,
you have an issue.
-I-I just need a -- I'm going to
step away for a second.
-Okay.
-Elizabeth looks like
Cruella de Vil.
Where's your Dalmatians, bitch?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoa.
-"I was in the hot tub
when you offered shrimp."
[ Laughter ]
"I was in the hot tub
when you offered shrimp."
-Can you get me some shrimp?
-I didn't know you had shrimp.
I was in the hot tub.
It's the best.
Guys, I read that the
world's top producer of
mozzarella cheese
says that it expects
shipping delays
to last all year.
Meanwhile, Papa John's
released a statement that said,
"Yeah, this doesn't
affect us whatsoever."
And, finally, in an effort to
save money on cleaning crews,
a city in Sweden
is using crows to pick up
cigarette butts off the streets.
I guess some birds
are destined for the Pentagon,
while others are stuck
picking up old cigarettes.
Today is Groundhog Day.
Yeah. That's right.
We spend all year telling people
to trust science
then ask a large rodent
to predict the weather.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, this morning,
Punxsutawney Phil
predicted six more weeks
of winter.
[ Audience groans ]
Asked why, Phil said,
"'Cause it's February."
[ Laughter ]
"You guys
have calendars up there?"
Meanwhile, in New York,
we have a groundhog,
and this is real.
In New York, we have a groundhog
named Staten Island Chuck.
[ Laughter ]
It's true.
And he predicted early spring.
-Oh.
-He's just like
Punxsutawney Phil,
but he wears a gold chain
and smokes a vape pen.
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, spring."
[ Clears throat ]
Well, this made me laugh.
On Sunday, Queen Elizabeth will
celebrate 70 years as monarch,
but more than 10,000 souvenirs
marking her platinum jubilee
actually has a typo.
This is real.
It says, "Platinum Jubbly."
[ Laughter ]
10,000.
Look at this. This is real.
Check it out. Zoom in.
-Ohh.
[ Laughter ]
-The Queen was not happy
with the plates.
For the rest of the day,
her office sounded like
a Greek wedding.
[ Glass breaking ]
"Opa!"
[ Laughter ]
Some sports news --
today, the Washington
Football Team finally announced
their new name.
Yep, unfortunately,
due to a typo,
they're going to be called
the Washington Jubblys.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Actually, Washington changed
their name to the Commanders.
They made
the announcement today,
but the name was actually leaked
last night
when a news helicopter
spotted it on a banner
inside the stadium.
Take a look at this.
-Yeah, going out there,
and they just kind of zoom in,
and then they saw that.
[ Laughter ]
News director was like,
"Uh, what else have you been
looking at with that camera,
Lou?"
[ Laughter ]
Every creep with a drone was
like, "Damn, way to up the game.
That's not bad, not bad."
[ Laughter ]
And today, there's another
football story
everyone's talking about.
Former Miami Dolphins coach
Brian Flores is suing the NFL
and three teams, claiming that
their hiring practices
are racist.
Right now
NFL coaches are so white,
when they win the Super Bowl,
they're like,
"I'm going to Vineyard Vines!"
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this, guys --
NASA just announced that it will
retire the
International Space Station
in 2031 by crashing it
into a remote part
of the Pacific Ocean.
[ Laughter ]
Plan was put together by the
new head of NASA, Vin Diesel.
[ Laughter ]
Wouldn't it be safer
to just leave it in space?
I know there's plenty of room.
It's called space.
[ Laughter ]
People like, "I need space."
That is space.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, get this -- I read that
malls across the country
have been filling
empty retail spaces
with surgery centers.
-Oh.
-That explains the store
I saw the other day
called Appendectomy & Fitch.
[ Laughter ]
Now I get it.
And, finally, a man in Canada
spent three days
building a giant snow bear
in his backyard
as an early Valentine surprise
for his wife.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Take a look at this thing.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, when he said, "Surprise!"
she was like,
"Doug, I watched you
make this for three days."
The 2022 Beijing Winter Olympics
are officially under way.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
♪♪
I love the Winter Olympics
because it features
the last people on Earth
who stuck to their
new year's resolutions.
At this year's games,
there are 91 countries,
109 events, and 1,000 chances to
hear the person next to you say,
"I could do that."
But tonight was the big
opening ceremony, and it was --
It's fun, because the only place
you see all the countries
get together are the Olympics,
the United Nations,
and International
House of Pancakes.
So it's exciting.
I read that the official motto
of the Winter Games
is "Together for
a Shared Future."
Yeah, when asked where
they got it from, China said,
"A Verizon commercial."
Meanwhile, the Winter Olympics
have an official mascot.
Did you see him?
Named Bing Dwen Dwen.
Here he is.
-[ Audience awws ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
Looks like something you'd win
at a rest-stop claw machine.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I saw that every Olympic
sport has its own unique logo
designed for the Games.
For example,
here's cross-country skiing.
Yep, and it turns out, while
these are official Olympic logos
for Olympic events,
they're also unofficial logos
for other things.
-Really?
-I'll show you what I mean.
Here's another logo.
Officially, it's speed skating.
Unofficially, it's your aunt who
just found out about dabbing.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Here's -- Here's the next logo.
Officially, it's luge.
Unofficially, it's trying to
fit in your jeans from 2019.
[ Laughter ]
[ Steve pops cheek, squeaks ]
Here's another logo.
Officially, it's figure skating.
Unofficially, it's that annoying
show-off at yoga class.
It's like, "All right, yeah."
Here's the next logo.
Officially, it's skeleton.
Unofficially,
it's Spotify's stock price.
That's interesting.
-Oh, wow.
They have a logo for that?!
-That's the logo for it.
-Wow!
-Finally, here's one last logo.
Officially,
it's short track speed skating.
Unofficially, it's racing to get
the last rapid test at CVS.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Hey, I heard it's going to be
the first Winter Olympics
that relies almost entirely
on fake snow.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
They're going to create
over 1 million cubic meters
of fake snow, or roughly one
Hallmark Christmas movie.
Well, get this --
a company in China
just unveiled plans for a plane
that can fly
7,000 miles per hour,
which means that you can go
from New York to Beijing
in 60 minutes.
Yeah, the company said
it's perfectly safe
and that your eyeballs
return to their sockets
within hours of landing.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news.
I saw that Costco is once again
selling a 5-pound tub
of Pillsbury cookie dough.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Imagine picking up a 4-pound tub
of cookie dough and going,
"Nah, I wanted the bigger one."
Yep, Americans saw 5 pounds
of cookie dough and said,
"Do you believe in miracles?!
Yes!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Yes!"
And finally, you guys,
we're all so excited
that the Olympics are here,
and of course
we're pumped
for all the big events,
but there's one event
that doesn't always get
the most attention.
Until now. Take a look.
[ Techno beat plays ]
♪ You think
that all Olympic sports ♪
♪ Are glory, gold, and fame,
they're not ♪
♪ But there is one that stands
above that isn't playing games ♪
♪ No more games, forget
the slopes, forget the ice ♪
♪ No, I'm not in the mood,
not tonight ♪
♪ 'Cause I want to sing about
tonight is doubles luge ♪
♪ Two buds, one sled,
try to stay alive ♪
♪ Bodysuit skin tight,
spooning while we drive ♪
♪ Spoon me,
first sprint, then slide ♪
♪ The hard work never ends ♪
♪ We shoot through all the tubes
just like a colon cleanse ♪
Ohh, ow!
♪ Flying fast, making turns
in sync with my teammate ♪
♪ I whisper in his ear,
"You're really doing great" ♪
♪ Milliseconds for the win ♪
♪ We simply cannot lose,
don't lose ♪
♪ Pelvis on pelvis,
that is doubles luge ♪
♪ Again ♪
♪ Pelvis on pelvis,
that is doubles luge ♪